- I smile because
I know how this ends up.
And I win, and you lose.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("New Beginnings" by Fiifi Jr.)
DRock, I'm gonna start with
this little shout out to
Nate on Snapchat.
Heading to the
Knicks game with Nate.
I love Nate.
Saturday night 6:36,
hot date with Nate.
Nate's a real Suns fan.
- So that's funny but
he was born in Arizona.
Got our tickets.
You excited Nate?
- Fired up.
- [Gary] You got your Suns gear?
- Suns gear.
- [Gary] Alright what
do we got today?
It's gonna be a short episode,
weekends are always--
Are we doing the sushi thing?
Maybe we'll have
some filming to do.
Is Travi setting it up proper?
Looks like we'll
have a continuation of
some filming for
DRock which is good,
so maybe we'll get
some more content but
I'll go on Instagram Live
in a second, actually maybe
I'll go Facebook live.
What's on my mind?
I was reading some
comments today here and there.
Same old fucking themes.
(DRock laughs)
Nothing too crazy,
same old themes.
- [DRock] The amount of
people that are making money.
- It's been good.
- I know what I wanted
to do in this episode.
I wanted to get you mother
fuckers to subscribe, I realized
I don't do hardcore
right hooks to subscribe.
You know how we used to
do the flash up of follow
Gary on Instagram?
We wanna do a
little bit more of that.
But also subscribe, do a little
red one for the subscribe.
We really don't.
I wanna do it in midst of,
the amount of people who are
watching everyday
and discovering
and then not subscribing
which then doesn't
remind them, I mean DRock.
There was something
else I wanted to talk about.
Nate, I'm on this new concept.
Comment muscles.
- [Nate] Comment muscles.
- So you know how some
people get beer muscles?
Like, they get, Av, you know
what I'm talking about, right?
They get a little
liquor in them and they think
they can fight.
Comment muscles.
- [Avi] Like sports muscles?
Exactly like my sports
muscles, that's exactly right.
So I have sports muscles I go
to a Jets game all of a sudden
I can beat up people and I wanna
start fights and it's crazy
but I'm noticing a lot of
people have comment muscles.
I got in this rabbit hole in a
flight back from London where
I went back to like
40, 30 episodes ago
and all the way back
to episode 12, 15, 19, 27--
It would be cool if you
did little clips from there.
Quote kind of went like,
the guy or gal that grows up
cooking with their grandmother
in the kitchen is always
gonna beat the person that
goes to culinary school it was
kind of the essence of doing it.
He said that that quote inspired
his friend and changed that
person's life and is now at,
ironically, one of the great
culinary schools
and has a profession
and that's kind of funny,
but, you know, its just crazy.
I wish it on all of you to know
that even though you're
going after your
own self-interests,
by proxy, by saw dust,
by process, you're bringing
so much good to the world,
it's an incredibly
intoxicating feeling.
I get equal if not slightly
more value out of
putting in the actual work
that has allowed me
the attempt for the
audacious goals that
I've created for myself.
Soon as I started
seeing kids who never had an
entrepreneurial
bone in their body,
who never sold
a thing in their life,
who never cared
about any of that stuff,
and were coming of
college and starting businesses
that's when I was like,
24 months ago,
that's when I was like, uh-oh.
This is starting to get a little awkward.
- [Woman] I would
like to just read the very
last paragraph of your book.
- [Gary] I have a scary feeling
that a lot of people will
show up to this.
I told you it's so crazy.
Did you see this?
We've been getting some
snaps that makes us feel like
there'll be a little bit more.
London I'm humbled, I love you.
Crazy clarity about tonight,
yes, the park is gonna be
closed and we're just gonna
meet outside on the corner.
Like that's how I'm rolling.
DRock your gonna need
to look at what I just saw.
Fuck.
Jesus Christ.
Alright this is
gonna end up a little bit
bigger than we thought.
Fuck me.
Thanks for being here.
DRock, help me, DRock!
(shouts)
(crowd cheers)
Holy fuck.
Alright, let's do it.
I started seeing way too much
chatter of people not being
able to make it I was like
maybe we'll meet 20 or 30 people
on the corner, I kind of
misjudged it a little bit.
(laughing)
Anyway.
And the amount
of you mother fuckers
that have comment muscles,
things like "GaryVee, watch
out, I'm coming after you",
and then I click,
and one year later you
ain't coming after shit.
You're in the same exact spot,
talking about the same things,
making the same damn
excuses, doing nothing.
So, comment muscles.
I want to create a culture
of eliminating a lot of you
from comment muscles
and getting into action.
Everybody's a tough guy with
their anonymous fucking name,
and their two cents
in a comment on YouTube,
and on Instagram,
and those places.
It's a whole different thing
to do something about it,
and so while you're
critiquing everybody's actions
on the web, and
adding your "two cents",
people are going out
and making three cents.
You understand?
So all you comment heroes,
all you people with comment
muscles, wake the fuck up.
Nobody gives a shit.
99% of people think you're
trolls and really delete you.
I just let you stay in
my comments and I smile.
I smile,
because I know how this ends up,
and I win and you lose.
(electronic music)
Usually I just end it with,
ya know I like
my dramatic little
"and I know how it ends up"
and we cut into
some fucking music.
(electronic music)
Not this night, this night I'm
gonna tell you what happens.
What happens is
you keep commenting
and nothing fucking happens and
I continue to do and execute.
And then you're gonna cry
and then in 20-fucking-29,
you're gonna leave
a comment on whatever,
on doodoo.com,
and you'll be like
"you know what? Fuck it,
"I gotta really hand
it to GaryVee, he did do it."
You're exactly right,
mother fucker, I did do it.
Because I've already done it,
and I'm gonna continue to do it,
and you're gonna leave
your snarky-ass comment
with no fucking
icons and I just feel bad.
I want you to do
better than that,
because I'm gonna get mine.
You're not
bothering me for shit.
I like it. Keep leaving them.
Fires me the fuck up.
Love it.
You know me, Nate.
This is how I play basketball.
I like it.
It's the only,
Nate, tell them the only time,
I don't know if you
even know this anymore,
'cause you've really kinda
retired from basketball but
I'm not gonna feed you it,
but like, there's
no way for me to ask it
without feeding you it.
I think I genuinely
hit more baskets
when somebody's
hand's in my face
than when people
leave me wide open.
- You just like the game?
- [Gary] I do, it's just
like I'm driven by it.
It's why I think I really,
- [Nate] Think about when
you hit me in the head.
- Yeah, that was a bad moment.
(group laughter)
Why'd you have
to bring that up?
I was on a roll and
you just killed my vibe.
You killed my vibe.
Do you remember
how mad AJ was at me?
- Oh yeah, AJ got,--
- [Gary] AJ was the most upset.
- I didn't know what happened.
- [Gary] You were fine,
what do you mean?
- [Nate] I was fine.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Nate] I was fine,
but I didn't even know
- [Gary] What
happened was, you know,
like I was a little bit
harder and needed to be.
Here's the bottom line.
- [Nate] You like
the back and forth.
- You're a classic
2010 basketball player.
I come from the 90s when like,
those kinds of hits were normal.
Avi, you know what
I'm talking about,
those 90s Knicks teams.
- [Avi] The old Knick teams.
Yeah, that was fine.
I felt it was super appropriate.
- [Nate] I wasn't that upset.
- You know what, to your credit
I don't want to put
you on blast, you're right.
Everybody else was more upset.
'Cause you're a competitor.
You're a competitor too,
I wrote that whole
Medium post about him.
Link that shit up.
Nate's fucking here.
Nate's sitting in
this car right now
because he's good at volleyball.
- [DRock] And tennis. Ehh.
- [Gary] Ehh.
Nahh, you never
lost to Nate in tennis.
- [Nate] Oh man.
- Yeah, that hurts, right?
You wish you won that five,
what was the best
one you had? Five?
- I think it was five-two.
- [Gary] Five-two, right?
- And then you came back,
- Yeah, that hurts.
So what was I gonna say?
Oh, so the reason
I think that I'm very built for,
and this is a good segue.
So many people are like,
how do you deal with the haters?
So many people
aren't putting out content.
So many of you are
not doing things right now
because you're worried
about people's feedback.
And it drains you,
and it kills you.
And somebody saying
you suck, you're ugly,
you're fat, you're not smart,
shut the fuck up,
nobody cares, you were
privileged, you had it easy.
It cripples you.
Not me.
I just don't
know how to tell you.
Not me, it feeds me.
I love the love.
You guys know.
Even the last episode,
I said compliments.
I feed off compliments
and I feed off hate.
Now stop me.
What up Instagram?
What up, what up, what up, Max.
Is it ready?
Tyler.
People are waiting for DailyVee.
Alright, we got
our place for sush.
Zero percent complaining.
It's always good to see
the Vayner peeps in here.
Nate, you want to
say hi to Jeff Kates?
Are you guys friends or do
you guys have a weird rivalry?
- No rivalry.
I don't feel
like I have rivalries.
- [Gary] You
have zero rivalries?
- Like from the office or
former people in the office?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I don't think
I have rivalries.
- [Gary] I mean here's
my take on that, people.
Zero rivalries means
you're not doing it right.
- [Nate] With my coworkers?
- Just in life.
You need rivalries, Nate.
- I have rivalries in life.
- Who is your
biggest rivalry in life?
Trouty?
- You know two people,
back in the day,
who will really like
this who are watching.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Was Andrew Augustyniak
and Jake Homiessy
who were both making deals.
- [Gary] Okay.
- We have a few
rivalries on the golf course.
- [Gary] And now
you guys are friends?
- I haven't talked
to them in a while, but.
- [Gary] Oh, if they're watching.
You just assume
everybody's watching now?
I appreciate the love.
You're my rival, Gary.
Well then Jessie G,
you're in deep shit.
Alright I'll see you later?
You'll join us?
- [DRock] Yeah.
Does he know
DRock's joining us?
- [Nate] What's up?
Do they know
DRock's joining us?
- Bye DRock.
("White Lines" by K.A.A.N)
- Big Suns win, DRock.
- Bigger Knicks loss.
Yeah, setup for the lottery.
10:11.
Knicks lost.
Sushi time.
It's called the
transition cut, DRock.